you
all right
check check check check check one two
three check check check one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten man
check check check one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
good where'd you go party huh
are you both going to talk an infuser
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
Tom Hauser house
how's it
give a photographer here folks thanks
for being here today I'm John Stiles
with attorney general Allison's office I
just want to make clear that attorney
general Ellison will be speaking today
and then taking your questions he will
not be able to answer any questions
about evidence or how evidence is
evaluated any question about witnesses
any question about the timeline of
events that led to mr. Floyd's death or
any investigative detail it is all under
investigation of this currently
confidential so I just want to set that
expectation right now with that attorney
general malleson
first of all thank you ladies and
gentlemen the press on my myself and my
friend Mike Freeman who want to share
some information with you I want to
begin with a reminder and that is that
we're here today because George Floyd is
not here he should be here he should be
alive but he's not about nine days ago
the world watched Floyd but it's very
last words I can't breathe as he fled
for his life the world heard Floyd call
out for his momma and cried out don't
kill me
just two days ago when I became the lead
prosecutor in the murder of mr. Floyd I
asked for time to thoroughly review all
the evidence in the case and we looked
at case the evidence that's available in
the investigation is ongoing at this
time I also said that I know it's asking
a lot of people to give us time
particularly people who have suffered
for decades and centuries of injustice
to be patient and yet we did get that
time and together a very strong
experienced team which included County
Attorney Mike Freeman his team and my
team we reviewed the evidence together
with the BCA and we have something to
announce today
before I announce that I want to say
thank you for the pictures of the people
who they've shown me and our entire team
in pursuit of justice and I'm here to
make these announcements right now first
today the I filed an amended complaint
the charges the charges former
Minneapolis police officer Derek Chavan
with murder in the second degree for the
death of George Floyd I believe the
evidence available to us now supports
the stronger charge of second-degree
murder we've consulted with each other
and we agree second today
arrest warrants were issued for former
Minneapolis police officers Jay King
Thomas Lane
and to Tao finally I'd like to announce
that today in a becoming attorney
Michael Freeman and I have filed a
complaint that charges police officer
King laying in towel with aiding and
abetting murder in the second degree
a felony offense I strongly believe that
these developments are in the interest
of justice or mr. Floyd his family our
community and our state I'm the lead
prosecutor in this case I'll be speaking
on May Jessamyn the public and this is
but this is absolutely a team effort we
are working together on this case with
only one goal justice for George Floyd I
want to thank first mr. Hennepin County
Attorney Mike Freeman who has been a
true partner in this matter at every
step of the way his experience and
insight have been invaluable and will
continue to be counted on by the team I
also want to thank Tony Attorney
Freeman's professional staff who have
cooperated and worked together with my
staff and the investigating officers
every from the very minute this case
started I also want to thank
superintendent to evident Evans of the
Bureau of Criminal Apprehension and his
professional staff for the care and
speed with which they are conducting
this investigation and I want to thank
especially US Attorney Erica McDonald
and Special Agent in Charge Rainer drol
Skagen who are conducting a parallel
federal color of law investigation
I have heard directly from the
leadership of the Department of Justice
that there is full support for her
leadership in pursuit of her
investigation and as she put it so well
one team one goal one mission I agree
100% as I said earlier I think mr.
Floyd's family I think and I can speak
for mr. mr. Freeman and I jointly thank
them along with
a US Attorney McDonald we thank the
community for their patience and
allowing us the time and space we need
over these days to lay these charges as
it is so hard to do I now ask for
continued patience this case continues
to be under investigation we will not be
able to say very much publicly about the
investigation except that we encourage
anyone who believes that they have
evidence in this case to come forward
and to be cooperative with the
investigation as we develop the case for
prosecution which will which will also
not be a we will not be able to say very
much publicly about it because our job
is to seek justice and to obtain a
conviction not to make statements in the
press but to put do our talking in court
so I ask for your patience again while
we limit our public comments in pursuit
of justice I also ask for your trust
that we are pursuing justice by every
legal and ethical means available to us
I also want a word of caution the
investigation is ongoing we are
following the path of all of the
evidence wherever it leads we are
investigating as quickly as we can
because speed is important we're also
investigating as thoroughly as we can
because being complete and thorough is
critically important but it takes time
the reason thoroughness is important is
because every single link in the
prosecutorial chain must be strong it
needs to be strong because trying this
case will not be an easy thing winning a
conviction will be hard in fact John the
attorney Freedman is the only prosecutor
in the state of Minnesota who has
successfully convicted a police officer
for murder and he can tell you that it's
hard I say that I say this not because
we doubt our resources or our ability in
fact we're confident in
we're doing but history does show that
there are clear challenges here and we
are going to be working very hard and
relying on each other and our
investigative partners and the community
to support that endeavor to the Floyd
family to our beloved community and to
everyone that is watching I say George
Floyd mattered he was loved his family
was important his life had value and we
will seek justice for him and for you
and we will find it the very fact that
we have filed these charges means that
we believe in them but what I do not
believe is that one successful
prosecution can rectify the hurt and
loss that so many people feel the
solution to that pain will be slow and
difficult work of constructing justice
and fairness in our society that work is
the work of all of us we don't need to
wait for the resolution and
investigation of this case to start that
work we need citizens neighbors leaders
in government and in faith communities
civil and human rights activists to
begin rewriting the rules for a just
society now we need new policy and
legislation and ways of thinking at the
municipal state and federal levels the
world of arts and entertainment can use
their cultural influence to inspire
change that we need there is a role for
all who dream of a justice that we
haven't yet experienced in the final
analysis a protest can shake a tree and
can make the fruitball that fall down
but after that fruit is in reach
collecting it and making the jam must
follow the demonstrations and the
protests are dramatic and necessary but
building just institutions is more of a
slow grind but equally important and we
have to begin that work as well
we need your energy and we need
everyone's help right now thank you very
much we'll take a few questions we
believe we have a duty to charge the
charges did fit the facts in this case
when we heat that we have done so and so
our concern is - but all the energy we
can into putting forth the strongest
case that we can without fear or favor
of anyone or anything there's these
charges are based on the facts that we
have found and we're going to pursue
them
the becoming attorney you did an
excellent job by gathering facts and has
worked cooperatively with us at every
single step of the way we consulted with
each other on these charges we believe
that these are the right charges Mike
Freeman and ice will be we've signed a
complaint for these additional charges
and so that's that's what we're doing so
[Music]
unfortunately I can't delve into our
deliberative process but what I will
tell you generally is we gathered all
the facts that we could we reviewed the
criminal statutes we looked at case law
we consulted with each other and we
arrived at these charges we believe that
they're justified by the facts and the
law the pursuit of justice is always
good and right and we I want to signal
to them that we hope that they continue
to raise the cause of justice but do it
in a peaceful manner it is their right
to express themselves and with that I
will say that they should they should
continue in their own communities to get
together to build just police community
relationships we need the faith
community to be involved we need arts
and entertainment to help inspire us
toward justice we need everybody there's
a lot more to do than just this case and
we ask people to do that
[Music]
you know I want to thank you for asking
that question because part of my
comments were to help set expectations
in a realistic light but you know in
order to be thorough this is going to
take months and I don't know how many
but it is better to make sure that we
have a solid case fully investigated
researched before we go to trial than to
rush it
we don't wear and so it will take a
while and I can't set a deadline on that
[Music]
[Music]
well according to Minnesota law you have
to have premeditation and deliberation
to charge first-degree murder
second-degree murder you have to intend
for death to be the result for
second-degree felony murder
you have to intend the felony and then
definitely the result without
necessarily having it be the intent so
that is the that's the state of the law
the family would be the well he was we
would contend that George Floyd was
assaulted and that and so that would be
the underlying felony you know I really
don't have any any idea of what the
negotiations or anything like that
that's simply way too early to begin
that conversation at this point we are
preparing to try this case if something
else happens along the way we'll see but
at this point we don't have any we don't
we don't have any plans in that
direction you know that is something
that I will I don't have anything to
report right now at this time we're
focused on investigating the case and so
I think at this time I'll I will consult
with the BCA and other partners on the
case and we'll come to a conclusion
about that again we believe in
transparency but we also believe in a
thorough investigation most importantly
I'll allow mr. Joe Evans to address that
issue yeah I good afternoon my name is
Joe Evans I'm the superintendent the
Minnesota Bureau of Criminal
Apprehension we were in the process of
taking the officers into custody I can
report that one is in custody now and
the other two we are in the process of
taking into custody and expect them to
be this afternoon
[Music]
I will as the Attorney General said we
can't speak about all the details of the
case other than what's really in the
complaint at this time I will tell you
with any investigation as I've told you
all from the very beginning we have
teams of investigators from the BCA
jointly investigating this with the FBI
trying to obtain all information in this
case I will tell you that is a regular
course of all of our investigations to
attempt interviews with all the officers
we haven't interviewed numerous
individuals in this case and additional
information will be provided as we move
forward
at this time I believe we have the team
to complete this work I would like to
just introduce David Boyd as well he is
a deputy at the attorney general's
office he heads the criminal division
and he he has the lawyers to get this
done and also we have some experienced
lawyers of the Hennepin County
Attorney's Office we're working on this
thing together in terms of the timing of
this decision I know the Floyd family
was hoping to be able to have more
information on these charges before the
memorial tomorrow how much did that
factor into your decision as well as the
protest with them calling for these
across the country as well in the
growing unrest there you know I can say
that I did not allow public pressure to
impact our decision making process I was
prepared to withstand whatever calls
came we made it the chart we made these
decisions based on the facts that we
have gathered since this matter occurred
and made the charges based on the the
law that we think is applies so that's
that's that's my answer I'm fine well
great I spent a lot of time in Hennepin
County when I was a trial lawyer myself
and I know a lot of you I know all these
I know all the lawyers there I respect
them all of my ramallah
work going on fine can I introduce you
okay Andy Lefevre he's represents
Hennepin County Attorney's Office it's
first deputy at for Mike Freeman right
know that I'm gonna let the people who
prosecute cases every single day to
prosecute this case now it is true that
I've tried a lot of cases and I've tried
homicide cases but on the other side of
the courtroom the people who know how to
prosecute I'm gonna let them do that
work you know I think it helps me
anticipate what some of the some of the
attacks on our case might be I see no
reason why we can't get a fair trial
here
yes well yes sir no I'll continue to do
all the duties that I have which involve
legislative which involve a lot we've
been very active in the civil space
we've been active in representing state
agencies and government will be I'll
continue to supervise that as I always
do but I feel I feel very confident in
it because I have excellent
professionals who are going to be
focused on this like a laser beam every
single day
take us into that room when the decision
was made for you personally I feel a
tremendous sense of weight I feel that
this I feel this is a very serious
moment I can honestly tell you I take no
joy in this but I do feel a tremendous
sense of duty and responsibility I don't
know the answer to that question maybe I
I would just answer that in terms of
that is left up to the various sheriff's
that we work with on this they make as
commissioner schnell noted the other day
security decisions in the best place for
everybody in light of everything that's
going on right now in the Twin Cities
again those are decisions based on the
analysis of the sheriff and they work
closely with the Department of
Corrections to make sure that they have
everybody in their custody where they
should be based on safety assessments
thank you all very much mr. Attorney
General
can you give us a little message for the
protesters who have been calling for
first-degree murder charges that may be
disappointed with this development what
would you say to them I will say to them
that I pledge and I promise to hold all
to everyone accountable for the behavior
that we can prove in a court and that if
I don't charge it it means that we did
not have the facts to do that so I'll
simply say that as the people who are
legal professionals professional
prosecutors we are taking our duty
seriously and we are working with the
people who are there
facts and this is and we are and we have
done that we have done the work that we
we believe is possible ethical and right
because there's a lack of trust there
with those professionals and then doing
their work which is why a lot of us has
come about yeah well I mean the only be
honest here I mean our country has had
has under prosecuted these matters in
Minnesota and throughout the country and
so I think the trust as a result of
historically not holding people who are
public Guardians accountable for their
behavior in situations where we should
have so that I think is the origin of
the trust problem but we can't we can't
control the past all we can do is take
the case that we have in front of us
right now and do our good faith best to
bring justice to this situation
and we will
it's a long overdue wake-up call to the
country that there are too many of these
cases where african-american men die in
police custody
under fairly brutal circumstances it's
clear to me that policing and among them